merci beaucoup on vous retrouve demain à
mes côtés dans balances ton post on vous
montrera le sommaire tout à l'heure et
franchement je suis très content que
vous soyez avec nous est ce que tes pump
et vous manque agathe tpm même tpm
paiement bien sûr j'ai quand même passé
toute la saison dernière avec vous mais
je vous regarde toujours jeux séparés
que vous nous regardez tous les soirs
oued et que j'ai le temps je vous
regarde ce qu'ils veulent toujours
autant c'est une de mes émissions
préférées bamert six mois ça fait
plaisir et il anticipe à l'échalote et
donc d'après vous est secrètement
amoureux d'agathe attentes hi à votre
bonnet qui se dressent
[Applaudissements]
sa critique ou d'agathe oui elle a
quelque chose qui me plaît
espèce de l'espèce de quoi espèce de
neurones rose neurones roses rouges à
lèvres c'est le glace elle est belle et
intelligente qui avait l'intention à 4
vous êtes s'il battait ce que ça pour
être votre style je ne suis pas
célibataire
[Applaudissements]
il en a détourné doute vous dominicaux
grand séducteur intéligent au bout
sympathique pour moi moi à oui j'étais
une meuf franchement élevage tour
enlever ton bonnet